voyage sans passeport
car elle Parma voici Prague qu'est-ce
que nous voyons au fond c'est le Château
de Prague c'est là que réside
généralement je crois les présidents de
la République
la résidence du Président de la
République
c'est le quartier ratjani c'est autour
du château de Prague c'est le vieux
quartier ce qu'on appelle la vieille
ville non c'est pas la vieille ville
c'est le quartier du château qui entoure
le château de radjani ici où sommes-nous
c'est le palais d'archevêque et là ce
sont aussi
une vie d'un oui oui c'est la vue du
pont
j'ai tout pointu c'est la cathédrale
Saint-Guy
c'est une très très belle ville que la
vôtre
vous avez beaucoup de ponts je crois
n'est ce pas il y en a beaucoup de ponts
il y a un le plus vieux c'est le pont
Charles Kappa on va le voir en détail
tout à l'heure afin de ne plus rien en
ignorer mais avant nous faisons un tour
général de la Ville pour revenir sur
de nouveau sur le château Raja
et ici c'est un détail je pense de la
cathédrale Saint-Gilles de la cathédrale
Saint-Denis
elle est très vieille elle est très bien
quel est son style c'est surtout la
gothique
et nous voici je pense à l'intérieur
c'est à l'intérieur de la cathédrale
je me rappelle la voix visitée
et là nous allons pénétrer si je mémoire
dans le refuge des bijoux les rois de
Bohème
des chapelles de la cathédrale
Saint-Denis
c'est très ancien ça c'est presque
barbare
et nous laissons je pense ici les bijoux
du couronnement pour d'autres monuments
et pour les tombeaux des rois
beaucoup dorment là-bas
je pense que tous les rois de Bohème de
rond là-bas
et ça c'est la vue que l'on a de Prague
sur management
de la cathédrale sur manasranas ça veut
dire c'est la vieille ville c'est un des
quartiers les plus vieux n'est-ce pas la
vieille ville malastronas ce sont mes
quartiers les plus vieux de Paris et ça
c'est la Tour Eiffel
et maintenant c'est toujours la vieille
ville
avec ses toits c'est tours qui semble se
répandre l'une à l'autre c'est la place
de la de la vieille ville
avec
l'hôtel de ville avec l'horloge je crois
qu'on va la voir fonctionner elle est
assez curieuse et très belle
voilà chaque heure les personnages
sortent c'est ça
je pense que la mort représente le temps
qui s'en va
toujours un quartier de quelque chose
toujours la vieille ville et c'est
l'église
de teen
dans la vieille ville
je crois qu'il y a toujours un toit pour
deux fenêtres c'est curieux n'est-ce pas
oui ça provient des moyennes
qui était renouvelé il y a maintenant
après la dernière guerre mondiale
l'architecture ici est extrêmement
touffue c'est un peu rococo
les archives de la ville
de la ville de
et ceci c'est le théâtre
de Till où l'on joue je crois des pièces
dramatiques n'est-ce pas
et puis maintenant la tour du pontcharge
oui des côtés de la vieille ville
c'est-à-dire ce qui tourne le dos à
monastrana il faut traverser le pont
pour aller vers manage Strana
derrière malade
il y a des personnages tout le long du
pont
il est très romantique ce pont du reste
avec ses deux portes une peau entrer une
pour sortir
et ici nous sommes nous sommes nous
avons une vie sur un malostense qui n'a
Amnesty ça veut dire c'est la place de
malade
c'est pas la rue de Neruda non c'est pas
Larry d'un Neruda ça c'est porjalette ça
c'est une place à côté du château oui je
me retrouve assez mal
l'architecture est très typique c'est la
rue de Neruda voilà
le château c'est pas la Renaissance on
peut dire que c'est la rue des
ambassades il y a une certaine nombre
d'ambassade que qui se trouve dans la
rue
et ceci
ce n'est pas l'entrée de l'église de
Saint-Nicolas non
il y a beaucoup de paliers
et ce sont les trésors de l'église
Sainte Loretta tout si c'est de l'or
que de sentiments d'éblouissant
et ici nous sommes nous sommes devant le
pavillon d'été la reine en
et voici maintenant vu d'hélicoptère je
pense Prague
et nous vous le quartier mal astral
on dit de prendre quelle est la ville au
centre je crois oui c'est vrai on dit de
prendre que cette
on dit assez souvent aussi Prague doré
et elle a aussi de nombreux ponts
12 je pense c'est ça
en effet il y en a des tours
qui s'adresse
et voici les ponts les 12 ponts de
Pragues
il ne me reste plus qu'à vous remercier
car elle Parma
vous a proposé voyage sans passeport en
compagnie de Karel Parme
réalisation Solange Peter montage Michel
Latouche crypte Lucette Andriy sont
Christian artelot illustration sonore
Dominique palladin